Putain les gars, faut des idées fraiches là ! On fait la suite de Jumanji !
Nan mais allo et puis arrête d'être sur ton téléphone aide nous à trouver des idées un peu toi !
Mais attendez mais je bosse là
Oh l'mytho, il envoie des emojis à sa femme.
Mais justement, j'travaille...
Emoji le film
T'es viré !
Ouais ouais j'comprends
Bon quand est-ce qu'on décolle ?
Bah, nan ici on fait des chewing-gum monsieur
Mais nan on est chez AirWays
Ah non, AirWaves
Alors là, les gars, j'étais dans une boite
qui s'appelle AirWaves mais c'est pas du tout une compagnie aérienne.
C'est jolie comme stylo. Quand est ce qu'on décolle ?
Alors oui, justement, on a quelque chose à vous dire...
Donc, vous vous souvenez forcément de l'ancien logo Google
On s'en lasse !
Quelle horreur ! Toutes ses couleurs... On est pas des bébés.
Heu...Attendez... Parce que...
Du coup...ça... ça c'est l'ancien, pardon...
L'ancien...et le nouveau logo Google
Ahhh
Bienvenue à la toute première réunion !
Installez-vous ! Voilà, vous avez des bonbons, des bouteilles et tout !
Vous voulez quels stations ?
Peu importe...
Allez, je mets "Fi"
Vraiment, il faut une stratégie!
*Brouhaha*
Mais qu'est ce que vous faites chez moi ?
C'est qui eux ? Ah oui c'est vrai, c'est la 2e
réunion. C'est ça, essayez-vous...
Au téléphone : "ouais t'es avec qui là ?"
Ouais, t'es où exactement ?
D'accord
Vous êtes viré.
Bonjour, je cherche un emploi.
Vous êtes au bonne endroit.
Vous cherchez quel poste ?
Conseiller pôle emploi.
Ça tombe bien, un poste vient de se libérer.
Vous êtes embauché !
Le dernier était beaucoup trop maladroit.
Pff c'est pas mon genre !
Vous êtes viré !
Ton petit maillot, tes chaussures...
On t'a mit des chaussettes de rechange
Le ballon
Oui, le ballon aussi, allez.
Je voulais pas y aller moi...
Oui  bah fallait pas...hein. Allez !
Salut les amis !
C'est ça, casse toi.
Ciao !
Oui... bare-toi
On accueille le nouveau gros YouTuber.
Il a 2 millions d'abonnés OK.
Ah bonjour !
Vous parlez de la petite starlette ?
La petite Lou, elle est là !
Moi, je suis juste le caméra man.
Elle a décidé de faire des vidéos de sa propre initiative.
Et le petit frère.
Petit frère qui va bientôt faire des vidéos
Des P-E-T-I-T-E-S V-I-D-E-O-S !
Il a commencé à bouger les pieds. Moi je films juste.
Allez souriez les filles, souriez. On a du tubes.
SOURIEZ, SOURIEZ, FAITES LE BUZZ ! FAITES LE BUZZ !
Je vous présente le futur du déplacement.
L'hoverboard !
*Brouhaha* Incroyable !
D'accord, donc il reste même plus.
Oui...
Pardon, je crois qu'il y a un problème d'impression dans le logo de votre émission
parce qu'il manque une lettre là.
C'est Koh Lant...
Ce qui est sur c'est que vous, vous êtes particulièrement collant.
Excusez monsieur. Moi j'aimerai bien au niveau de l'alphabet
Regardez, j'ai B, C, D, E, F, ça veut rien dire. C'est quoi la première lettre s'il vous plait ?
Juste pour savoir.
Allez retourner à l'école !
Ca suffit !
Oui, merci Monsieur Brogniart.
Tu vois, c'est en permanance comme ça.
Tout les jours, on me casse les couilles
Je suis désolé...
Mais vous lisez quoi ?
Oh Denis! Denis! Deunis!
Je...je...c'est un accent
"Rires"
en permanence comme ça. Tous les jours
ah bah je me suis trompé voila
fallait qu'j'la fasse
faut que je le fasse maintenant?
souriez! faites du buzz!!!
allez on sourit on va faire un p'tit prank
alors on va la mettre... vous avez pas une poubelle ou un truc comme ça ?
[bafouillage]
et toi arrête d'être sur ton téléphone
aides-nous à trouver des idées un peu!
attendez mais je bosse là!!!
oh le mito il envoie deeeeeeees
non mais c'est OK
Ici il y ... Tu vois ?
Oui c'est plus équilibré
[ Rires ]
Ils vont se chier dessuuuuuus !
Merci
Mais bien sûr que c'est possible ! Regarde, moi j'suis un hologramme depuis le début.
Mais naaaaan ?
Nan je déconne moi aussi je suis un hologramme depuis le début en fait
Bah, mais? Mais nan
[ Bruitages ]
Téléportation !
Oh put*in !
Mais, casse toi, toi put****in
Alors on fait un brainsto'
On sort du brainsto' là
Alors nan parceque là y'a.. Joli stylo!
Oui, justeman
"Rires"
Le "justement" en même temps mec il est magnifique là
Pour faire quoi? "Bafouillages"
"Rires"
Bon, moi aussi j'avoue je suis un hologramme depuis le début
Mais non!
Ouah, j'avoue, moi aussi
Et... non
Mais non! Et j'le fait avec vous c'est plus "Mais non!"
"Rires"
Cest plus que le salaire de Gérard? C'est plus! Mais non!
Mais c'est pas possible...pour un...un téléphone, bah attends moi j'vais reprendre l'alcatel
Vas-y bonne soirée tout le monde
C'est pour le bêtisier y'a pas eu de bide encore.
"Rires"
Voila y'en a un
Ohhh! Ohhh Non!
Ohh! M*rde!Ohhh!
Oh!
La nouvelle collection! At-tends-tends-tends j'vais rattraper l'coup!
Oh non! Ah c'est pire!
"Rire"
Ohhh non
Chut, chut, chut!
Bah c'est super!
"Rires"
ça c'est super pratique pour s'déplacer
Vous êtes viré
Bonjour! Je cherche un emploi!
Vous êtes au bon endroit!
Y'a trop de crayons, vraiment..
"Rires"
Les copains?
"Poufements" "Rires"
AH! -bonne toi!